So today we're going to continue
with what we did last week
and we're going to talk about something
called rationalizability.
And I'll say up front that I think today
is the first class where maybe there'll
be a bit more notation, a bit more math.
So if anything's unclear, if some
notation isn't clear, feel free to ask
me questions cuz there's probably other
students who also find it unclear.
So first let's remember or recall
how we defined a strategic form game.
So remember a strategic form game
specified the strategy sets for all of
the players and also the payoffs for all
of the players.
So one way I'll often write it
is U
from S1
SN
to RN.
So what does this mean?
This U function assigns to every profile
of strategies some vector of payoffs.
That specifies each of the N players'
payoffs. So with this notation, we might
think of a strategy profile S
is going to get mapped to a vector U of
S, which is just all the payoffs the
players get put together in a vector. So
we have U1 of S
all the way up to UN of S.
This tells us player one's payoff if the
profile of strategies that's played is S
all the way up to player N's payoff if
the profile of strategies that's played
is S.
And I'll point out here that
we're generally going to use lower case
U throughout the course. So in the first
couple of lectures, we made this big
deal, I which I think correctly so,
about the distinction between the von
Neumann-Morgenstern utility which was
defined over consequences
and then expected utility that was
capital U and that was defined over
lotteries, over consequences.
But throughout the course, as we start
talking about beliefs and mixed
strategies, it gets a little cumbersome
to think, you know, every time should
this be capital U or lower case U?
So I'm throughout the course from here
on out going to always use lower case U
with the understanding that that can
represent expected utility if there's
any
um beliefs or mixed strategies or moves
by nature in the extensive form. But as
we get to more complicated things, it's
just a little less clear when it's big U
and little U. So I'm just going to stick
to little U as long as we understand the
conceptual distinction.
So what we talked about last time is
which strategies were reasonable to
play. So last time we talked about
strategies that were reasonable
and I'm I put reasonable and
unreasonable in quotes because I don't
mean these in really formal terms. I'm
just being a little informal here.
But let's remember
we called a strategy reasonable for a
player
if it was a best response to some
belief.
So I'll say BR for best response to some
And let's remember what a belief is.
A belief that player I has is a belief
about the strategies chosen by all of
the other players. So whenever I talk
about player I's belief that's a belief
about the partial profile of strategies
played by the other players.
And then we alternatively said we can
think of a strategy as unreasonable
if it is strictly dominated
which we defined last week.
And crucially it wasn't enough to just
think about strict dominance by another
pure strategy. We had to consider strict
dominance by mixed strategies. So if
it's strictly dominated by some mixed
strategy.
And what we showed last week is that
these are two sides of the same coin.
Either a strategy is a best response to
some belief
or
it's strictly dominated by some mixed
strategy, but every strategy falls into
exactly one of these two categories. So
you can take a positive view and say, I
only want to play a strategy that's a
best response to some belief or you can
take the negative view and say, I don't
want to play a strategy that's strictly
dominated by some mixed strategy and
either approach you take is going to
give you the same set of strategies.
So today we want to be maybe a little
more formal.
I don't really love this terminology,
but we'll use it and we'll say that
we'll say what it means for a player to
be rational
in this context. We'll say player I is
rational
well, if player I plays a strategy
that's in this good collection of
strategies or equivalently is not in
this bad collection of strategies. So
I'll say player I is rational
if she plays
a best response to some belief.
That is the strategy she chooses is a
best response to some belief about the
other players' strategies.
I want to be a little careful using the
term rational. This is a a word that's
used in a lot of different ways in a lot
of different contexts, but in this
specific context of game theory, this is
usually the term that's used, so I'm
going to use it, but I warn you that in
other game theory courses you might take
or other things you see, rationality can
be defined to mean different things cuz
it's an important, difficult concept.
But let's look at this definition.
And it's restrictive in that the player
must be playing a best response to some
belief. So the best response part of it
is what imposes some restriction.
But notice there's no restriction on the
belief here.
So the res- the assumption or the
restriction of rationality by himsel- by
itself is a very weak requirement
because it doesn't constrain or
discipline the beliefs that player I
forms about the other players'
strategies. So this is purely about
player I's rationality and it says
nothing about the other players'
rationality.
But let's think a little bit
and let's say
what if not only is player I rational
but what if player I
knows or believes that the other players
are rational, too?
Would this change the way that player I
might play or would this impose any
additional restrictions? What do you
think? What might change if player I, in
addition to being rational herself also
knows that the other players she's
playing against are rational?
Yeah.
Uh it changes
beliefs that the player I knows that the
other players are limited in their
strategy
>> [snorts]
>> Exactly. Right. So uh do you want to say
more or yeah? Yeah. Yeah, great. So I
just didn't want to cut you off. Um
exactly. So before we had no
restrictions on beliefs. We said all
player I is going to do is they're going
to play some best response to a belief,
but we don't know where that belief
comes from. But now if player I knows
that the other players are rational,
they shouldn't form a belief that
assigns positive probability to a really
weird, bad strategy that a rational
player wouldn't play.
So the idea here is that this is going
to
restrict
or constrain
the beliefs that player I should or
reasonably would form about others.
Constrain beliefs
about other strategies.
And do we stop there? Are we done or can
we keep going?
Yeah. Then I guess the other players,
from their perspective, would update
based on player one playing what they
believe is player I's strategic
strategy.
Right. So you might think, okay, now not
only
is it relevant if I know that the other
players are rational, but do I know that
the other players know that I'm
rational?
Because if the other players know that
I'm rational, that's going to affect the
beliefs that they form about my strategy
and therefore affect further restrict
the way they might play and therefore
further restrict the beliefs that I
would form about them. Now I think you
can see pretty soon this is going to get
pretty complicated and just writing it
in words is going to become cumbersome.
So now we're going to try to take a
formal approach to this kind of
reasoning that captures what's often
called
higher order knowledge of rationality.
So first order knowledge of rationality
means I know other people are rational.
Second order knowledge is I know that
they know that I'm rational. And third
order, I know that they know that I know
and we can see how this goes on and on
and on and we want to capture these
higher degrees of knowledge about
rationality in order to make more
precise or sharper predictions about
play in the game.
So let's go through this is a bit
abstract. So let's go through an example
to try to convey this idea and this is
going to be the same example we did last
class, but we're going to add in the
payoffs for player two as well. So we're
going to have
game like this.
Remember player one is always the player
who chooses rows and player two is
always the player who chooses columns.
We always put player one's payoffs
first. So, we're going to have
2 0
-1 1. Copy from my notes here.
So, last week
we used these same payoffs for player
one, but we didn't specify any payoffs
for player two when we talked about this
game. And just as a reminder, we
represent the game in this nice normal
form, what's sometimes called a
bi-matrix cuz it's a matrix of numbers,
but each entry has two numbers, so bi
for two.
Uh but let's remember what's going on
here. S1, the set of strategies for
player one, are just the rows of this
bi-matrix. So, we have
top middle and bottom.
And S2
for player two is just left and right.
Okay, so let's try to start going
through this procedure of
rationality.
So, let's first think about well, if
player one is rational, what strategies
might they play?
And a good way of going about this
that's sometimes helpful is to say, well
we know that rationality is a bit
complicated because we have to consider
all possible beliefs about the other
players.
But let's start with the simpler beliefs
where we know what strategy the other
player is playing.
So, if I'm player one
and I know that my opponent is playing L
then I can just look down and say, well
I get two if I play T
I get zero if I play M and I get -1 if I
play B.
So, the best response for me as player
one is to play T.
And we often denote that by underlining
the first entry here.
So, the fact that we're underlining
player one's payoff means we're thinking
about player one's best response to
player two's strategy.
And the fact that it's in the first
column
tells us we're thinking about player
one's best response to player two
playing L.
Now, let's do the same thing if player
two plays R.
If player two were to play R, then
player one knows that they get -1 if
they play T
zero if they play M
and two if they play B.
Two is the highest number there, so
we're going to underline this.
And we can immediately see
two strategies that are reasonable for
player one.
T and B.
Now, the trickier part is are there any
more? Does anyone remember? So, M here
is not a best response to L or R, but we
haven't actually checked if it could be
a best response to a belief where I
think you play L with some probability
and R with some probability. Does anyone
remember is M a best response to any
belief that player one has? You're
shaking your head. The answer is no, and
why? What How do we know that?
Yeah. There's a theorem
theorem that says
that
>> [clears throat]
>> either a strategy is a best response to
some belief or it's strictly dominated.
Exactly right. And you're saying that
this is strictly dominated by something?
Um
It is. It is going to be strictly
dominated by something. This is what we
went over last week that was a bit of a
while ago. We said that M is strictly
dominated by the mixture of playing T
with probability half and B with
probability 1/2. That's something we
checked last week.
So, we know that the only
reasonable strategies for player one
are T and B.
So, let's maybe
think of that as step one.
And when I say step one, I'm going to
say, let's assume or suppose that both
players are rational.
And just from that assumption alone,
what can we conclude about the
strategies that might be played? So,
player P1 and P2
are both rational.
Well, if they're both rational, we've
said that that tells us something about
what player one can play.
So, I'll write S1' here to say, let me
collect together the strategies that
player one could play or might
reasonably play if player one is
rational.
And in this case, we just get T and B.
And now let's try to do the same for
player two.
So, let's go through the same procedure.
Suppose I'm player two.
Imagine player one is playing T.
Then I get zero if I play left and one
if I play right. Right is better, so I'm
going to underline it. And notice here I
underlined the second number
because here I'm keeping track of the
best response by player two to the
beliefs they have about player one.
And I'll do the same thing here. If
player one plays M, I can get 10 or
zero. 10 is higher, so I'll choose L.
And if they play B, I can get -6 or
zero. Zero is higher, so I come here.
And we can immediately see that R is a
best response to some strategy
and L is a best response to another
strategy.
So, in this case we're already done
because we already see that both of
these strategies are reasonable.
Each of them is a best response. In
fact, in this case, not only to some
belief, but to a belief that puts all
the probability on a single strategy.
So, here
we'll say S2'
equals L and R.
And notice an important point here
rationality doesn't always restrict the
strategies that a player might play.
In player one's case, player one's
rationality does throw out one strategy.
It threw out M because M was strictly
dominated by another mixed strategy and
was never a best response to any belief.
But for player two, even if they're
rational, we can't say much more. We
can't say anything else about what they
might play because what's best for them
depends upon what player one does. And
if player one plays T
it's great for them to play R.
And if player one plays M, it's great
for them to play L. So, we can't rule
out any strategies yet.
So, that's kind of step one.
Now, let's go to step two and impose a
bit more
you know, slightly strengthen our
assumptions. Let's now say in step two
we'll maintain our assumption that P1
and P2 are both rational
but we'll add the further assumption
that each player knows that the other
player is rational.
So, I'll say and
to remind you that I'm maintaining the
assumption up here
each knows
that the other is rational.
So, our numbers are kind of off here.
This is we could call that step zero,
but this is first order knowledge of
rationality here in step two.
So, now let's
maybe write S1'' to be prime
to be the strategies that player one
could play if player one is rational and
knows that the other player is rational.
So, if player one knows that player two
is rational
what can they conclude from that?
Well, in this case actually not much.
They know that instead of the player
playing something in here, they're going
to play something in here. Well, those
are the same. So, actually in this case,
player one's knowledge of player two's
rationality doesn't change things and
we're actually going to get the same
answer down here.
We're going to get T and B.
Because in this case, my knowledge of
player two's rationality doesn't
actually restrict the beliefs that I
form.
But let's do the second player. I think
this will be a bit clearer.
What about player two?
So, now that player two
knows that player one is rational, how
does that change player two's beliefs?
Yeah. Well, I'm going to play right
Great. So, let's let's go through that
slowly. So, if I'm
player two
if I know that player one is rational, I
can reason through the way player one
would behave and I can say, if player
one is rational, they're only going to
play T or B. Those are the only two
strategies they could play.
And then I'm going to look up and I'm
going to say, okay if player one plays T
then I'm better off playing R.
And if player one plays B, then I'm also
better off playing R.
Now, we have to be a little careful here
because I might also think, well
maybe they'll play T with some
probability and B with some probability,
but it turns out even if they play those
with some probability, you'd still be
better off playing R. And the reason is
that, well
R is strictly better than L given T and
strictly better than L given B. So, it's
not too hard to check that if they
formed a belief about those two things
R would still be better.
So, now
we go down to R.
So, what changed when we moved from step
one to step two?
Notice the set of strategies that we
think player two might play or could
play has gotten smaller.
Not because player two is rational. We
already assumed player two was rational.
But what further restricted our
prediction or sharpened our prediction
was our assumption that player two not
only was rational herself
but knew that player one was also
rational. And by thinking through how
her opponent being rational might play,
player two was able to restrict things.
So, now let's see if we can go one step
further.
So, now it gets a bit cumbersome to
write, but maybe I'll say step three
is what? It's that and each player knows
that each other player knows that the
other player is rational. This is a a
trickier to say, but
and
knows
that
the other
knows
that they are rational. It's a bit
sloppy, but
So, if we if we read through this from
player one's perspective, player one
knows that the other player, player two,
knows that they, player one, are
rational.
And similarly, player two knows
that player one knows that player two is
rational.
So, we might If we want to write this in
words, it's like one knows that two
knows that one is rational, and two
knows that one knows that two is
rational. It's kind of two different
statements here, and the arrows indicate
knowledge, right? This is that two knows
that one is rational, and this is that
one knows that two knows that one is
rational, and so on.
And maybe now we'll call this S1 triple
prime,
and S2
triple prime.
Well, S2 triple prime is pretty easy
because player two we've already
narrowed it down to the only strategy
they have left. So, that's just still
going to be R.
And that's not going to change.
But what about player one?
What is player one
What is reasonable for player one to
play given this second-order knowledge
of rationality?
Thoughts?
Yeah.
B, right? Because now, if player one
knows that player two must play R,
then they look up and they say, "Well,
if player two plays R, I've already
actually underlined it.
B is my best response to R.
So, if I know that player two is playing
R, then my best response is B."
And notice here the structure of this
when I go through the steps. We write S1
triple prime and S2 triple prime next to
each other.
But what defines S1 triple prime is
actually my knowledge that player two
is playing a strategy in S2 double
prime. And similarly, S2 triple prime is
driven by player two's beliefs
about what player one is going to play
from S1 double prime. So, we're always
kind of looking back to the step before.
The step before pinned down how my
opponent would play,
and now adding one other layer of
knowledge tells me that I know my
opponent will play that way, and that
may allow me to further restrict the
strategy that I use. This kind of this
crisscross pattern as we go down.
And now we're done.
Uh in this case, there's no strategies
left uh to deal with, and we can check
not a coincidence here that we have one
strategy left at the end, one strategy
profile left at the end, BR, and notice
that both
um B that both numbers in that cell are
underlined, which reminds us that B is a
best response to R, and R is a best
response to B, which uh makes sense and
and will hold a bit more generally.
So, notice here that here
this approach, or we might say
rationalizability, or we haven't defined
that yet, but let's say here um
we get
a unique
prediction.
When we apply this algorithm, um
eventually we got to a point where each
player only had one strategy left.
But that doesn't always hold.
So, let's emphasize this is not always
the case, as we'll see later.
But when this is true, we have a name
for it. So, when we have a game where we
can go through this procedure, and we
get a unique prediction for each
player's strategy, we call that game
dominant solvable. So, when this does
happen, it's not guaranteed, but when it
does happen, we say the game
is dominant solvable.
Underline this.
Why do we call it dominant solvable?
Well, simply by reasoning about
dominance. Remember, we often reasoned
about best responses, but that's
equivalent to reasoning about dominance
by a theorem from last week. So, all we
really needed to use is that players
don't play strictly dominated
strategies.
They know their opponents don't play
strictly dominated strategies. They know
their opponents know that they don't
play strictly dominated strategies. They
know their opponents know that they know
that their opponents know that they
don't play strictly dominated
strategies, and so on. And simply by
reasoning about dominance, we're able to
solve the game in the
sense of identifying a unique prediction
in the game.
Any questions on on this so far?
So, now we'd like to formalize this. We
went through it in an example, but let's
introduce the formal algorithm that uh
is going to go through this procedure.
So, this algorithm is called
rationalizability.
Or it has two names.
So, it's either called
rationalizability,
and rationalizability is really a
statement about the strategies that
survive this algorithm. So, in this
example, we would say strategy B is
rationalizable for player B, and
strategy R is rationalizable for player
two. Sorry, player one and player two.
But the procedure we use is often goes
by a different name, which is the
iterated
elimination
of strictly dominated strategies.
And sometimes this goes by the acronym
iterated
elimination of strictly dominated
strategies,
cuz it's a bit of a mouthful.
But the idea
at each step,
we implicitly threw out the strategies
that were strictly dominated. We
eliminated the strategies that were
strictly dominated, and we did this
recursively or iteratively, and that's
why we call it iterated elimination of
strictly dominated strategies.
To formally define this procedure, we
need some notation, right? It was easy
in this example to kind of work through
it, but to do it more generally, we're
going to need some general notation.
So, we really need two um pieces of
notation to start. So, let's consider
player I.
So, given player I,
and
some collection
of strategy profiles of the other
players. So, we're given player I,
and I'll say S negative I prime,
which is a subset
of S negative I.
So, remember, S negative I is the
collection of all profiles, or we might
say partial profiles, of strategies of
my opponents.
And S negative I prime is just an
arbitrary subset of those strategies,
of those strategy profiles. So, it's
just some collection of strategies that
my opponents might play.
And now we want to define two things.
The first thing is BR I
of S negative I prime.
So, what this is going to be is the set
of strategies
for player I
that are best responses to some belief
about my opponent's strategies
that only puts positive probability on
strategies in here. So, let's go through
this, right? Remember we said
we have to think through what beliefs
are reasonable, and we only want to keep
track of strategies that are best
responses to certain reasonable beliefs.
So, let's define this a bit for more
formally.
First of all, the key thing about this
is this is these are strategies for
player I.
So,
here as I said, I'm going to use
some notation that maybe we haven't done
before.
I'm defining a set here,
and the way I'm you building up the set
using set builder notation is I'm going
to say this set contains every strategy
little SI in the set big SI that
satisfies some additional property.
So, this is kind of the universe of
things I'm considering, and then I'm
going to impose some constraints over
here that narrow down which elements of
this set I actually allow for.
So, what does it mean for SI to be in
here? Well,
a strategy SI is in this set if SI
is a best response
to some belief
beta negative I.
Now, if I just stop there, we'd be back
to what we did last week. We would just
be thinking about being a best response
to some belief.
But now I want to impose the restriction
on this belief. I want to say it's a
best response to a belief
that only puts positive probability on
strategies in this set, not any
strategy.
So, on some belief beta negative I
satisfying
Well, what's the way of saying this?
Well, this belief assigns some
probability to the opponent's strategies
being in this set.
And I'm going to require that that
probability is one.
So,
beta negative I of S negative I prime
equals one.
So, it's not enough
for a strategy to be a best response to
some belief.
It has to be a best response to a
particular kind of belief.
A belief that maybe puts,
you know, it could put probabilities on
different strategies in this set, but it
can't put any probability on strategies
that are outside this set. So, the
interpretation of this is if I know that
my opponents are only going to play
strategies in this set,
what strategies for me are reasonable?
And it's exactly the strategies that are
best responses to a belief that doesn't
put any probability outside that set, or
equivalently, puts all the probability
on the strategies
in this set.
Now,
we said from last week that there are
two ways of thinking about this. We
could think about what I should play and
what I shouldn't play.
So, now we want to look at the other
side of the coin, which is what are the
strategies that are strictly dominated
by some mixed strategy.
So, let's go here.
So, what this stands for is
strictly conditionally dominated.
So, last week
we talked about what it means for a
strategy to be strictly dominated by
another strategy, and it means some
other strategy does better however my
opponents play.
But now we want to be a bit more
permissive, right?
Again, we're going to have the
interpretation that I know
that my opponent strategies lie in here.
So, if I know that my opponent
strategies are in here, I'm not going to
for dominance, I'm not going to require
a strategy to do better however my
opponents play.
It's going to be enough if that strategy
does better
however my opponents play in this
restricted set.
And that's what the conditional
dominance means. It means conditional on
my opponents playing a strategy in this
set,
conditional dominance means one strategy
always does strictly better than the
other strategy. So, let me write it in
words and then we'll
be a bit more formal. So, again, this is
a collection of strategies SI
big SI
such that
SI is
strictly
conditionally dominated.
Now, if I say conditionally dominated,
strictly conditionally dominated, I have
to say what it's conditional on, right?
So, strictly conditionally dominated,
I'll say given
S negative I prime.
So, that's my condition. The condition
is I know my opponents are going to play
something in S negative I prime, and I'm
interested in conditional dominance
given that condition.
So, it's strictly conditionally
dominated given S negative I by what? By
some
mixed strategy.
And I think it's often tricky to get
It's easy to get confused here.
Is it dominated by a mixed strategy of
player I's or player I's opponents? What
should come here?
Yeah. Player I. Player I, right? So,
it's always player I's strategies that
dominate player I's other strategies.
The beliefs are about the opponent
strategies, but the dominance relation
is always between strategies by the same
player because the player is only
comparing their own strategies. So, by
some mixed strategy
sigma negative I.
So, here's the definition, or here's
Here's the definition of this set, but
I've sort of cheated a bit because I've
used a new word that I haven't yet
defined.
So, now I need to define that new word,
right? What does it mean for SI to be
strictly conditionally dominated given S
negative I prime by some mixed strategy
sigma I? Well, we already said it
intuitively, it means that whatever
strategy profile my opponents play in
this set,
sigma I is strictly better for me as
player I
than strategy SI.
And now we just need to translate this
intuitive idea into math, right?
So, I'm comparing
as player I
what I get from sigma I
to what I get
from SI.
And again here, we're using our
lowercase U's, even though what I'm
plugging in here is not a pure strategy,
but a mixed strategy. But remember what
we said at the beginning,
the interpretation is that this is just
my expected utility
over the lotteries induced by this mixed
strategy.
Okay, so we're comparing sigma I to SI.
We want SI to be dominated by sigma I,
so we know the inequality has to go this
way.
And it's strict dominance, so it has to
be a strict inequality.
But we're not going to require this for
every strategy of my opponents. We're
only going to require it for the
strategies that satisfy the condition,
right? So, this is going to be
S negative I
S negative I, but for which S negative
I?
For all
S negative I
that are elements of
S negative I prime.
Now, if there's two players, this is
pretty easy. S negative I is just a
strategy of my opponent.
But if there's more than two players,
remember, say there's three players,
then S negative I, let's say I is one, S
negative I specifies what strategy
player two chooses and what strategy
player three chooses.
And in this case, S negative I prime is
a collection
of strategy pairs
chosen by players two and player three.
They're still choosing separately, but
we're just putting them together
mathematically into a vector.
Are there any questions
on this? Uh I think this is kind of a
maybe the heaviest definition we've
done.
Any questions?
Okay.
Great. So, now
let's try to maybe I'll move to a new
board.
Let's try to
recall
what our theorem said last week
in this new notation.
So, often when we introduce new
notation, it becomes a lot easier to
express ideas that we've already
expressed.
So, let's recall the the theorem
from last week.
Well,
what we said is that a strategy is
either a best response or it's strictly
dominated. It's not both. But remember
last week, we didn't worry about strict
conditional dominance, we didn't worry
about restricting beliefs.
So, it was sort of a special case where
S negative I prime was just S negative
I. There wasn't any restriction on these
things.
So, our theorem from last week
basically said two things.
It said SI
equals
BRI
of S negative I
union
SCDI
of S negative I.
Let's try to go through this
in words. And first, let's think about
what the union means.
This is a set of strategies.
This is a set of strategies. When I take
the union, I'm thinking of the larger
set that puts together things that are
in either of those two sets. So, it's
like I have two bags of strategies, and
I pour them together into one big bag
that contains all of the strategies.
So, in words, this says
every strategy in SI
is either a best response to some
belief.
Notice here, I'm not There's no prime
here.
So, this is a best response to an
unrestricted belief.
It would only have a restriction if I
chose as S negative I prime a smaller
set of strategies.
Right?
So, another way of saying this is
if we go to this definition, well, if S
negative I prime is just S negative I,
then the fact that beta negative I of S
negative I equals 1 is not a restriction
at all cuz every belief assigns
probability one to the set of all
strategies, right?
So, every strategy is either
a best response to some belief
or it's strictly dominated. And again,
this means strictly conditionally
dominated, but strictly conditionally
dominated conditional on any possible
strategy just reduces to strict
dominance. So, strict dominance is a
special case of strict conditional
dominance. But this is only one part of
the theorem. What What else did our
theorem say? I mean, this says that
every strategy is in one of these two
sets.
But it said one more There's one more
thing we know about these sets.
Yeah? Each strategy is in exactly one of
the sets. Exactly one. So, what's
missing here? What haven't we What does
this allow for that that we we want to
rule out? It allows for a non-empty
intersection. Right. But what we know is
that that can't happen. So, what we also
know is that the intersection is empty.
That is, no strategy is in both of these
sets, right?
So, this is sort of our at least one
statement, and now we're going to just
using the notation we said last week,
this statement says that every strategy
is in at least one of these two sets.
But our second part of our statement was
that every strategy was in at most one.
What does it mean to be in at most one?
It means you're not in both.
So, what that means is BRI
of S negative I
intersection SCD of S negative I
is empty, and the math notation for
that, I'll just write this.
So, again, this is a collection of
strategies.
This is a collection of strategies.
Should have an I here.
And all this notation says in math is
that no strategy is in both of these
sets.
The intersection of these two sets is
empty.
Okay.
It turns out though that this holds more
generally.
So last week
we had the special case with S negative
I where we didn't put any restrictions
on these beliefs.
It turns out this holds more generally
if we put primes here.
So this holds
for any subset.
So let's kind of
work through this.
We started with S negative I. Now we're
using a smaller set of strategies. So
let's try to understand what happens to
these two sets.
If S negative I prime
gets smaller
so I'm considering fewer strategies that
my opponents might play
what happens to these two sets?
So this best response set, does this get
smaller or bigger as S negative I prime
gets smaller?
Say again?
I think someone had it. Yeah, smaller,
right? So this gets smaller. Why? Well
I'm not allowed as many beliefs, right?
This is the set of all strategies that
are best response to certain beliefs. If
I shrink the set S negative I prime, it
says I'm narrowing down the strategies
that my opponents might play
which narrows down the beliefs I might
hold.
So how many strategies do I have that
are best responses to this smaller
narrower set of beliefs? Fewer
strategies. So this set is going to get
smaller.
What about this set? As S negative I
prime gets smaller, what's going to
happen to this set?
It's got to get bigger, right? Well, one
way I'll explain in a second. One way to
see this is well
the union is staying the same size. So
if one gets smaller, the other has to
get bigger, but let's think through it
mathematically, right?
A strategy is dominated by another
strategy if that other strategy is just
better no matter what happens in here.
It gets easier to be dominated
if there are fewer strategies that my
opponents could be playing.
So it's easier to be conditionally
dominated if the condition is stronger,
right? One way of thinking about it is
just counting the inequalities, right?
If S negative I prime is a really big
set we have a lot of inequalities here.
These inequalities have to hold for
every element of this big set.
If SI prime becomes a smaller set, there
are fewer things to check. It's easier
to be dominated conditional on a smaller
set of strategies and therefore the set
of things that are dominated gets
larger.
That's what we see here.
Um
And in the extreme case, maybe one thing
to think through, in the extreme case,
what if this just has
a single element?
So special case
So what if S negative I prime contains a
single strategy profile S negative I
prime? So this is big S negative I
prime.
This is little S negative I prime.
Then what happens to this set? What is
this set going to be in words?
Yeah.
Um
Not quite. So it's actually just going
to be the strategies that are best
responses to this strategy. So remember
before we got into all these fancy sets
of strategies, we just defined what it
is for one strategy to be a best
response to another strategy.
So if this set just has a single element
in it it just says this is the the
collection of strategies that are best
responses to this particular strategy
profile of my opponent.
But then this gets tricky. Then that
means this is everything that's not a
best response
to this strategy. So how does that work
out? Why is everything else strictly
dominated then? That seems a bit tricky,
right? That seems like we have a lot of
strategies in there.
Remember strict conditional dominance
given one strategy is really simple,
right? All it means
to be in this set is that some other
strategy does strictly better
given the strategy of my opponents.
But that's exactly the same as saying
this strategy is not a best response,
right? If there's only one strategy of
my opponents, either a strategy is a
best response to my opponent's strategy
or it's not meaning another strategy
does strictly better given that strategy
of my opponents and that's exactly what
strict conditional dominance means in
the special case. That may have been a
little quick, sorry.
Any any questions here? Yes. So
is it always is it always strict that
every time we basically make SI
um
when we like shrink SI S negative I
prime
that BRI S negative I prime is going to
shrink or can it sometimes like stay the
same?
It could sometimes stay the same and and
I mean one way to see that is
uh
well
it's going to end eventually. So
eventually we're not going to be able to
take things out. That's one way of
seeing it. Um but you're right, we'll go
through an example like this. So um it's
not always the case that
uh
at each step things will shrink. Uh but
once nothing is thrown out, once
everything stays the same for one round,
then we're basically done with the
algorithm. But we'll we'll talk about
that
Okay, any more questions about these
relations here?
Okay, so now that we have our notation
we can formally define our algorithm. It
took us a while. We started by
motivating it. We gave these
definitions, but with these definitions
we can write the algorithm in a really
short clean way. So let's let's go over
this.
Okay, so here's our algorithm.
Maybe I'll write it kind of in a more
computer science-y way. So what's our
input
to the algorithm?
The input is just a strategic form game.
And I'll be a little more precise. Let's
say a finite strategic form game.
So
and if I just write it like we did in
the beginning, it's just a function U
and maybe I'll write S to RN.
And in a sense all of game theory is
just studying
functions like this, right? It's a
function that says for every strategy
profile the players choose what are all
the players' payoffs? Right? And this is
a vector that tells me player one's
payoff, player two's payoff all the way
up to player N's payoff.
And you can see this simple function
gives me everything I need to know.
Because the N up here tells me how many
players there are.
The S here tells me all the strategy
profile all the strategy profiles and
therefore all the strategy sets for each
of the N players. And then the function
itself tells me all the payoffs. So
that's really all I need to know.
I should maybe I'll put a star by finite
and I'll kind of say you know, what we
often do throughout the course is when
we talk about formal results, we assume
things are finite to make sure nothing
bad happens. The reason we do that is
when you move away from the finite case
there are some weird cases that can go
wrong.
But then we'll discuss a lot of examples
that aren't finite, but where things are
well-behaved and nothing goes wrong. So
we will apply these ideas to the
infinite case, but we just don't want to
claim make any formal claims about the
infinite case because you can come up
with some really weird infinite
discontinuous games where bad things
happen. But uh
we will, you know, if on an exam I say
compute the rationalizable strategies in
this game, you can't just say, "Oh, it's
not a finite game. I'm not going to do
it." Um you can't get out that easily.
So we are we are going to apply these
ideas to infinite games, but I'll
formally define it here for the finite
case.
Okay?
Uh so we're going to define things
recursively. So let's start with kind of
our maybe I'll call it the base case.
And the idea is we just want to go
through the algorithm we did before. We
want to start with all the strategies
and at each point we want to throw out
strategies that we don't think players
will play and we want to whittle down
the set of strategies until we get to
the the good ones at the end.
So the base case
um
we'll index things by K.
So I is always going to index players. K
will indicate the steps uh in this
algorithm.
So with K equals zero
well, we just say SI0
equals SI
for all I equals one through N.
So we haven't done anything here. We
just said at step zero
what strategies are left? Well, the
strategies that we started with.
And that's true for each of the N
players. So we've done nothing so far.
We've just formally um
gotten the algorithm going. We've
initialized things.
And now let's look at the inductive
step.
If you haven't seen taken an algorithms
course or seen proofs by induction, um
or seen recursive definitions, it just
means
after we start with case zero, well,
next we're going to go to step one,
and then we're going to go to step two,
and then we're going to go to step
three, but it takes a long time to write
out all those things. So, we're going to
kind of reason at an arbitrary step.
We're going to say, let's say we've gone
through steps up to K,
how are we going to perform step K plus
one? And if you know how to go from K to
K plus one, well, we already know how
zero, so then we can go from zero to
one, and then one to two, and then two
to three, and so on.
So, the inductive step, well, what's our
starting point? We're imagining that
we've already defined
these sets up to stage K. So, what we
have is we're given
maybe I'll write it out.
S1K
all the way up to SNK.
So, these are the strategies for player
one that have survived the first
the rounds up to round K. I guess we're
starting at zero, so it's really K plus
one of them, but the rounds up to K.
And SNK is the set of strategies for
player N that have survived so far up to
round K.
And what we want to do is to find which
strategies are going to be left at round
K plus one.
So, what do we need to do?
We're going to define
maybe here
say for each I
plus one, right? So, before I write
down the formula, let's just understand
what we have.
We have S1K through SNK.
We want to define SIK plus one for every
player I.
So, SIK plus one is the set of
strategies for player I
that survive up to round K plus one.
Any ideas based on the notation we've
done
given so far what
what could be here? I mean, intuitively
we want to keep in all the strategies
that are best responses to some belief
about our opponents that's consistent
with what we've calculated so far.
So, what we know at stage K is that it's
only reasonable for player one to play
something in here
all the way up for player N to play
something in here.
So, given that knowledge that player I
has, what is reasonable for player I to
play at this kind of round of the
algorithm?
Any thoughts?
Yeah. So, the BRI of
S
minus
um the other minus I, yeah? Uh
to the K. Exactly right. So, this is
going to be
BRI
of S negative I to the K.
Now, let me first define what this is,
right? So, I think we know what this
notation is, but let's be clear, this is
something like
S1K
all the way up to S I minus one K
times S I plus one K.
SNK. I think that makes it seem fancier
than it is. All it means is
I know the S I know the strategy set at
the Kth round for each of my opponents,
and I just want to put all those
together, making sure to skip myself.
Because I'm player I, I don't need to
form beliefs about my own strategies.
So, this is
you can think of it as or it exactly is
the set of
strategy profiles of my opponent such
that each player's strategy in that
profile lies in the corresponding
strategy set that we got at the end of
round K.
And more mathematically from our
definition here, these are the set of
strategies for player I that are best
responses to some belief player I could
hold that only puts positive probability
on strategies that are in this special
restricted set.
Now, there's another definition we could
use using our theorem over here. How
else could we define this step
that would give us the same answer?
Yeah. We could define the set as
basically like S I
the things that S D I S negative I
K. Exactly. So,
just like we always said, there's two
ways we can do it. We can keep in what's
good or we can throw out what's bad.
So, we could also define it as
everything in SI
except so, when I use this set minus
thing, I want to say the set of things,
so everything that's in here, but not in
here. And that's SCD
I
of S negative I
K.
And our theorem over here exactly tells
us
that those two are the same.
So, you could always use this
definition, you could always use this
definition, it's not going to make a
difference.
Uh this definition is maybe more
consistent with the name iterated
elimination of strictly dominated
strategies. That's literally what we're
doing here,
but we could also say iterated retention
of best response strategies, and that's
basically what we're doing here. Though,
I just made that up, that's not a a name
that's used. Um but that's one thing we
could do.
Um
Great. So, we're not done yet.
Because all I've told you is how to go
through each step. Step Oh, yes. Why
isn't the S sub I S sub I to the K?
Uh
here?
Ah, that's a good point. Um it turns out
you could do that and you get the same
answer.
So,
in the infinite case you have to be a
little careful, but in the finite case
you're right. If you put SI to the K
here, you would get the same answer. Um
I think conceptually
uh
it's I like to think I think this is
sort of conceptually more
better captures it that you know, here I
am, I'm player I. All I know at this
stage is that this is what the players
could do, and I want to throw out things
that are strictly dominated. So, it
doesn't
you know, there's no reason for me to
really think back to what I did before,
so I think conceptually maybe this is
more in the spirit of the algorithm, but
you're exactly right that mathematically
this is going to be a subset of SIK, and
if I put SIK here, and often when we do
the algorithm, that's kind of what we're
uh what we implicitly do in our heads.
Um so, you could put the K here, um and
it wouldn't In the finite case it
wouldn't change things. You have to be a
bit careful in the infinite case.
Um
Okay.
Great. So,
we've defined these steps,
but in general this could go on forever.
So, if we wanted to be really formal,
then what is the output of the
algorithm?
Well, the output of the algorithm is we
think of which strategies remain after
we do this infinitely many times.
It's a little weird to think about, but
the output technically we might call SI
infinity,
and this is the set of strategies that
survive every single round. So, if you
want to be really mathy about it, we
would say this is
uh SI zero intersect
SI one intersect SI two intersect and
dot dot dot.
And we could write that as the
intersection
from K equals zero to infinity
of SIK.
So, formally what does this set mean? It
means it's
I only include a strategy in this set if
it survives round zero,
it survives round one,
it survives round two, it survives round
three, and on forever.
And we call this
the set of
rationalizable
strategies for player I.
So, if you wanted to be really precise,
we might say that
iterated elimination of strictly
dominated strategies is an algorithm or
procedure, and that the output of that
procedure is the set of rationalizable
strategies. You might say
rationalizability is a property of a
strategy, and IESDS is a procedure that
we go through in order to identify the
strategies that have that property. But,
you know, on exams we're not going to be
too picky about exactly this distinction
between the algorithm and the output of
the algorithm.
But, you might say, well, wait, this we
have no hope of doing this.
We have to go through infinitely many
steps. That's that's a mess.
So, fortunately,
when we're in a finite
game,
the algorithm is always going to end
after finitely many steps.
And what do I mean by that?
So, I'll say fortunately,
this ends after finitely many steps.
Now, what does ending mean? It doesn't
mean I only have one strategy left for
each player. That happened in our
example, but that doesn't always happen.
But, what ending means, kind of going
back to the question earlier, is I get
to a point where I can't throw out any
more strategies.
And if I don't throw any more out of one
round, then I'm not going to be able to
throw any more out of the next round.
And basically the algorithm is just
going to become static. There's going to
be nothing else that happens.
So, formally what it means is for some
big K
so, after big K steps,
subsequent steps don't change anything.
So, I'll say for some big K
SIK, that's a big K,
equals
SIK plus one
equals SIK plus two
and so on
for all I.
So, what that says is, okay, once I get
to stage K,
if I were to apply step of the
algorithm, nothing would change.
And if I were to apply one more step,
nothing would change. How do you know
you've gotten to that point? Well, as
long as you get to a step
where nothing is thrown out,
you're done.
But let's be really careful. It's not
enough for there to be one player where
you throw nothing out.
If if if you throw strategies out for
any player, you might have to keep
going.
So, the algorithm is only done when
every single player's strategy set stays
the same from one round to the next.
You can even see in our example here,
when we went from step one to step two,
player two's strategy set, sorry, player
one's strategy set did not change.
But the algorithm wasn't done because
player two's strategy set did change.
And for that reason, we had to do one
more step. So, it's only when everyone's
strategy set is fixed that you're done.
Uh so, keep going
until nothing changes, and then you're
done, and what's left are the
rationalizable strategies. Now, let me
give a tip, I think, for exams, for
problem sets, when you're actually doing
this on your own.
This algorithm has a Or before I do the
tip, let me say,
how do we know that it has to end? If
you want to be a little mathy and think,
wait, how can we be sure it ends? Why
can't it go on forever?
Anyone know?
Well, there's only finitely many
strategies to begin with, right? And at
each round, we just throw strategies
out. We never get bigger. So, if we have
finitely many things, and we keep
throwing something out, we can't throw
things out forever. Eventually, we can't
get any smaller. Yes. Does that mean
that you can never swap strategies?
Like I guess I didn't understand. Like
throw one out and put another one back
Exactly, that will never happen. Yeah,
so at each step, these sets are getting
smaller and smaller and smaller. And
this exactly goes to the property we
were describing about how the set of
best responses gets smaller
as the set of opponent strategies gets
smaller. So, at each round, everyone
else's strategy set gets smaller,
but that means the set of best responses
I have gets smaller, which means the set
of best responses they have gets
smaller, and at each stage, we're just
throwing things out. Another way to see
Well,
um yeah, I guess it's not immediately
obvious from this. Uh but again, this
set gets smaller,
and this set gets bigger. We throw out
more things, and we uh we keep fewer
things.
If if it didn't have that property, then
it could go forever, right? We'd worry
that we might get in cycles, where we
take a strategy out, put it back in,
take it out, put it back in. That can't
happen. There's no cycles. We just get
smaller and smaller until we stop.
Yes. So, when you say it's a finite
strategic form game, does that mean that
the number of players is finite, as is
the number of strategies per player?
Yes.
Uh so, N is finite. I mean, uh we're
never really going to think of N
infinite, but technically, it means N is
finite, but the the real substantive
content of it is that the SIs are also
finite.
Okay, so here's my tip for doing this.
Because of this property that things get
smaller at every stage,
um
if you throw something out that you're
not supposed to,
you're done. You're really in trouble.
You've you've messed up. There's no
coming back from it.
But if you don't throw something out
that you're supposed to throw out, you
can always throw it out next time.
So, it's always safer to keep things in,
cuz once you throw it out, it can't come
back.
But if you keep it in, well, maybe it
just stays in a little too long, and
you'll throw it out next round.
So, it's it's better to err on the side
of inclusion.
Uh and for that reason,
my suggestion would be, when you're
going through it,
think about
dominance. So, I would say,
uh
use SCD
during the algorithm.
Why? Well,
if you're looking for strategies that
are strictly dominated, and you miss
one,
that means you forget to throw something
out.
And you can throw it out next time.
If you look for strategies that are best
responses, and you miss one,
then you're going to throw that strategy
out, and you can never recover from
that.
Now, the only problem though is at the
end, if I'm using this definition,
there's a risk that I might have kept in
too many strategies at the end.
So, my advice would be on the last
stage, once you think you're done,
then use this definition. And check that
everything that's left is a best
response to some belief about your
opponents. So, use SCD during the
algorithm, and then
use BR at the end.
And this is a safe way to make sure you
never throw anything out you shouldn't
throughout the algorithm, but then at
the very end, check that there's nothing
left that you should have thrown out.
Um so, that would be my advice for how
you go about it, uh if you want to be
safe. Maybe it's a bit slower, but I
think that's a safe way to do it.
Any questions on that?
Great. So, let's now do a few examples.
So, another simple example would be
the prisoner's dilemma.
So,
cooperate, defect, cooperate, defect.
I think last time we may have used the
phrases M and F, mum and fink, but in
the prisoner's dilemma, it's also common
to use cooperate, defect, cooperate,
defect.
Remember,
cooperate means cooperate with the other
prisoner, not with the authorities. That
can be a little confusing. So,
cooperation is a property of what the
players in the game are doing. So, it
doesn't mean testify against the other
prisoner, it means cooperate with the
other prisoner by not testifying.
So, here in the prisoner's dilemma,
we have Let's go through the algorithm.
Well, first,
what is S1 zero?
Well, this is just a set of strategies
for player one.
We already see what it is. It's CD. So,
that's easy.
And then, S2 zero also equals CD.
Okay.
So, now let's go So, this is step K
equals zero. Here's K here.
Now, let's go to step one.
So, at step one, what happens? Let's
follow our tip, and let's only throw out
dominated, strictly dominated
strategies.
So, what do we throw out here?
Well, cooperate is strictly dominated by
defect.
Right?
If my opponent cooperates,
I do strictly better
by defecting.
And if my opponent defects, I also do
strictly better
by defecting.
So, D strictly dominates C for each
player.
That means I throw out D.
And what do I keep in? Well, C. Sorry. I
throw out C, and I keep in uh D. Uh let
me say that again. I may have
jumbled my words. C is strictly
dominated by D, so I throw out C and
keep D.
>> [snorts]
>> And now I could go one more stage, but
actually here, one way you always know
you're done is if each player only has
one strategy left. But let's make sure
we didn't make a mistake.
Let's do our best response thing at
check at the end.
Is D a best response to D?
Well, we can actually go through our
procedure here.
So, I'm just doing the underlining that
we did before, and sure enough,
D is a best response to D for both
players, and we know
Well, we don't know we've done it right,
but we at least know we didn't obviously
do it wrong. Um
So, we're done there.
Let's do
one more example.
Uh
maybe I'll call
top, bottom,
left, right. So, again, two players,
uh two strategies each.
Let's do it like this.
And let's go through our procedure.
So, again, step zero is easy. We're just
writing down the strategies the players
have.
Player one's strategies are T and B.
Player two's strategies are L and R. So,
we have
S1 zero
equals TB.
And S2 zero equals LR.
And I'll warn you, when you look at
this,
it gets a little confusing when you see
things like S11. But I'm always going to
use the convention that the subscript is
the player,
thing at the bottom, and the superscript
is the round number, or the stage of
elimination.
So, I'll call these things K at the top,
and I at the bottom, but if they take
actual numbers, just remember, the
bottom is the player, and the top is the
stage that we're at.
Okay, so that's step one, step zero. Uh
Now, let's go to step one.
What do we throw out here?
Yeah. No strategies should be dominated.
Right. So, we don't throw anything out.
And how can we see that? Uh well, let's
go through our best response thing.
If I'm player one, if my opponent plays
L, I'd rather play T.
If my opponent plays R, we haven't
gotten to a case like this, but here I
have multiple best responses.
And it's really crucial when you have
multiple best responses to underline
both of them, because they're both
reasonable ways you could respond.
So, given my opponent plays R, I get
zero from both T and B.
So, I'm going to underline both of them.
And then we'll do the same thing the
other way. If player one plays T,
player two wants to play L.
If player one plays B, player two is
indifferent between L and R, so we
underline both of these.
And if we look at our underlining, we
see that T
is indeed a best response for player
one.
It's a best response to L.
And actually also to R, but L is enough.
What about B?
Is B a best response to anything? Yes. B
is a best response to R. It's underlined
here.
So, both T and B
are best responses to some belief.
And similarly, both L and R are best
responses to some belief.
Uh
L is a best response to both T and B
cuz we can see L underlined twice.
And R is a best response to B,
but not to T.
But that's okay. It's a best response to
something, so we get
S11
equals TB
and S21
equals LR.
So, do you have to keep going or are we
done?
So, now we're done.
But the reason we're done is that player
one strategy set didn't change and
player two strategy set didn't change.
But remember, we're only done because
every single player strategy set stayed
the same. It's not enough for just one
to stay the same.
Uh so, we're done here. We're done here.
And these two examples illustrate that
in some cases
this rationalizability procedure gives
us a very strong prediction about what
we'll play in the game.
But in other cases, it doesn't really
give us any sharp prediction at all.
We're not able to rule out any
strategies using this concept of
rationalizability alone.
Let me check the time.
Great. So, let me do one maybe more
substantive example to finish
that actually has continuous strategies.
So, let's go back to the beauty contest
game
that we played
uh on the first day of class.
And I think some people were starting to
go through this kind of reasoning. Here
we can formally get uh we can formally
solve this game.
So, let's go to the beauty contest.
But this time it's a bit easier to say
that you get to choose a number, any
number, any real number between zero and
100. So, you're not restricted to
integers here.
So, each player gets to choose, so we
have players I equals
one through N.
And each player I gets to choose a
number
between zero and 100. So, I'm following
the notes here and using X to be the
number that you choose
instead of S.
Well, let's write down our payoffs.
So, let's say I'm player I
and the numbers are chosen are X1, X2
all the way to XN.
So, we're going to consider here
uh the alpha beauty contest.
So, we're going to have some number
alpha
that's between zero and one.
And your goal is for your guess to match
alpha times the average of everyone's
guess.
So, on the first day of class we played
when the second day we played the beauty
contest with alpha equals 2/3, I think.
And
to make things a bit easier, instead of
just saying you either win or you don't,
we're going to say that your payoff
depends on how close you are to alpha
times the average.
You get the highest possible payoff if
you're exactly alpha times the average.
And the farther you are your guess is
away from alpha times the average, the
lower your payoff is.
And we're going to specifically do that
with what's called a quadratic loss
function. So, you lose the square of
your distance from your ideal guess.
So, what is that going to be?
It's going to be minus something
squared.
So, the thing squared, this is your loss
and you're subtracting this loss.
And what are we going to square? We want
to square the distance or the difference
between what you actually guess
and the ideal guess, which is alpha
times the average of the class.
So, this is player I's payoff.
So, I have XI here. That's what I
actually guess.
What's the best possible guess? It's
alpha times the average of everyone
else's guess, or average of everyone's
guess, I should say. So, that's minus
alpha times
X1
to XN over N.
And this is kind of a subtle aspect of
this game that my own guess contributes
to the class average, right? So, here
this is the class average.
There's N people in the class.
Each of them guesses a number, so I
divide by N to get the average guess in
the class.
Then I multiply the average guess, which
remember I as player I contribute to.
I multiply that average guess by alpha.
That's the the ideal guess. That would
be the the best possible guess I can
make.
If I guess exactly that, then my payoff
is zero. That's great. But the farther
my guess is away from my bliss point or
the ideal guess,
the greater my loss is or the more
negative my payoff is.
It turns out because it's a little
tricky to analyze this directly because
when I think about my guess, I'm also
changing the class average at the same
time.
So, it's better to just factor out the
XI. So, let's
uh write this a bit differently.
Um
So, we have XI here,
but then there's also an XI here and
it's multiplied by alpha over N.
So, what I get is 1 minus alpha over N
times XI.
The one times XI comes from here.
And the minus alpha over N times XI
comes from over here.
And then what I'm left with is alpha
times the sum of everyone else's guess
divided by N.
But that's kind of awkward to deal with
cuz there's only N N minus one people
and I'm dividing by N. So, I'd rather
divide by N minus one. So, let's
write this times as alpha
times
N minus one
over N
times X negative I bar
where this is
the sum over everyone but me
divided by N minus one.
So, all I've done is multiplied and
divided by N minus one. It's a little
algebra here, but I divided by N minus
one here. I wasn't really supposed to do
that, so I undid it by multiplying by N
minus one over here and I still have the
N that I'm supposed to have on the
bottom.
And this is just nicer notation cuz this
tells me what is the average of everyone
else's guess. And that's really the way
you think about this problem, right? You
think about your guess and you think
about the average of everyone else's
guess. It's a bit weird to think of the
class average, which partly reflects
your guess and partly reflects everyone
else's guess. So, this is just a
slightly nicer way of
of writing it though it makes things a
little messier.
Let's go
down here.
So, from this formula, it's also a bit
easier to calculate my best response.
So, let's imagine hypothetically that I
knew what the average of everyone else's
guess was.
Then I would want to choose my XI
so that this
equals this, right? And this should be
squared.
Right? I want my loss as small as
possible. I want this expression to be
zero, so I want this to equal that.
And now I'm going to solve for XI. So, I
want XI to be this
divided by this.
Just a little bit of algebra, which you
can work through at home if you'd like.
And what you'll find is that the
kind of best response, if I solve for
this, is I get XI equals
Well, I get the right side divided by 1
minus alpha over N and the N's kind of
cancel nicely, so I get
alpha times
N minus one
over N minus
alpha times X negative I bar.
So, what this says is if I knew
that this is what everyone else was
going to guess or more specifically,
this is the average of everyone else's
guess, then this is my best response.
This is my best guess.
Now, at first you might have thought you
would want to guess alpha times what
everyone else guesses, but that's not
what we get. Why do we get this
kind of
messy term here?
Well, first let's let's look at this
number. Is this number bigger than one
or less than one? Let's assume N is
greater than one. Otherwise, this is not
a very interesting game.
This is less than one.
Right? Because I'm subtracting one on
the top and I'm subtracting something
smaller on the bottom. So, that means
the bottom is bigger than the top, so
this is less than one.
So, that means
it's best for me to guess not alpha
times the average of everyone else, but
strictly less than that.
So, this is
less than alpha
x minus i bar. So, you have any
any intuition? It's a bit strange,
right? If you thought about this game,
you might think you just want to guess
exactly alpha times everyone else's
guess.
Yeah?
Exactly right. So, if if I said, "Okay,
everyone else the average is x negative
i bar." Let's say I guessed alpha times
x negative i bar.
Well, that sounds good. I'm guessing
alpha times the average, but now the
average is strictly smaller because my
guess of alpha times the average is
smaller than the average. So, as you
exactly as you said, I've pulled down
the class average and now I want to
guess a little bit lower. And that's
exactly what this is reflecting, the
fact that my
guess directly affects the class average
and when I'm trying to guess a
a fraction of the class average, my
guess is always going to pull it down.
Okay.
Um but, you know, not so important.
Let's just give this a name. We'll call
this alpha n. So, technically it depends
on this parameter alpha
uh oh, maybe just can and the number of
players we have. And as the number of
players grows large, it's going to get
really close to alpha because your
effect on the average is going to become
very small.
Okay, but now let's try to go through
our algorithm in this game.
Uh okay, running out of time, so let's
just do it quickly.
s i zero
equals zero to 100
s i one
Well,
the highest my opponents could guess
would be they all guess 100. And in that
case, I'd want to guess alpha n times
100.
The lowest I'd want to guess is zero if
everyone else guesses zero. So, we're
going to get zero to 100 alpha n.
And you can see the pattern. s i to the
k
is going to be zero times 100 alpha n to
the k. Because each time, if I know that
my opponents are only guessing up to 100
times alpha n, I want to take that and
multiply it by alpha n again.
So, in the limit, what we find
is that s i infinity
equals zero for all i.
So, this game is dominant solvable and
the unique rationalizable strategy for
every player is to play exactly zero. Uh
that was a bit quick, but uh this a
variant of this is on the homework, so I
didn't want to make it too easy for the
homework. Uh so, you'll get to work on
this in the problem set. Okay, I'll see
you all next week.